hi i'm benjamin hermann and this is a
video abstract
for my recent paper modeling
synchronization in forced turbulent
oscillator flows which was recently
published in communications physics
and you can find the link to the full
paper on the description below
this work was jointly done with philip
oswald and richard seman from team
branchvike
and with steven brunton from university
of washington
so let me start by defining what do i
mean by oscillator flows
these are fluid flows that display and
steadiness characterized
by a well-defined frequency and that are
rather insensitive to external noise
wake flows are a prototypical example
and even turbulent wakes are known to
exhibit a similar behavior
and these flows have been studied for
decades mainly due to their richness
as a non-linear dynamical and also due
to their relevance to applications
in aeronautics transportation and energy
conversion
and a great model to describe the
evolution of dominant patterns in these
flows
is the celebrated stewart landau
equation in this work
we leverage an extensive experimental
data set
to extend the stuart lambda equation to
model the response
of wake flows when periodically forced
and this is the example of oscillator
flow that we are working with
it's a d-shaped bluff body
that is very long in the span wise
direction so the flow is
quasi-two-dimensional
the body has a rectangular base
and we conduct wind tunnel experiments
at a reynolds number of 56 000
that is based on the body height and the
free stream velocity
the body has two thin slits located at
the upper
and lower trailing edges through which
we do
periodic blowing
and it has these two curved quanda
surfaces
on the back that deflect the outcoming
jets into the wake for a more effective
actuation
we have five time resolved pressure
sensors located
at the rear face of the body and
positioned in the center plane in the
span wise direction
and what we do with these signals is
take a weighted average
to obtain this output signal x
and if we take a look at the power
spectral density of x
we see one lonely peak located at the
natural frequency
which we call omega zero so this is the
frequency
of the unforced vortex setting in the
wake
and other authors have looked at the
power spectrum of
x when the flow or a similar flow
is periodically forced either at the
natural frequency or at an integral
multiple of it
here we take a look at how does the
power spectrum changes
for over 200 different forcing
frequencies
ranging between zero and three times the
shedding frequency
so if we take this 200 power spectra
and we vertically stack them one next to
the other
we get one of these heat maps and we
have six of them
because we consider three forcing
amplitudes denoted by epsilon
and two forcing configurations so the
first one which we call symmetric
forcing
where we are blowing through the top and
bottom jets
simultaneously and the second one that
we call
antisymmetric forcing where we alternate
blowing through top and bottom jets
so this is the enlarged view for one of
those plots
where again both axes represent
frequencies so the horizontal axis has
the forcing frequency omega f and the
vertical
axis has capital omega which denotes
the frequency content of the signal
x that is characterizing the weight
dynamics
and the color map denotes spectral power
so if we choose a forcing frequency and
take a vertical slice
in this plot the brightest spot along
that slice
will represent the dominant frequency
component in the wake
being excited at that omega f
and we also find the direct signature of
the forcing frequency
in the spectrum of the response and
that's colored by this green line
where capital omega equals omega f
and then we find these other regions
that we color
in in yellow and in light blue
which correspond to non-linear
interactions between the
forcing and wake modes giving rise to
these signatures
at omega f plus or minus omega
so these frequency components colored in
in yellow and light blue
are much fainter for the case of
antisymmetric forcing
meaning that triadic interactions play a
much lesser role in the wake response
of anti-symmetrically forced flows
as compared to symmetrically forced
finally to complete the picture all the
other
features that you see here can be
explained either as
higher harmonics of the forcing or the
non-linear interactions between the wake
and these higher harmonics so now that
we have a full
picture of what are the dominant
frequency components
in the wake response we can build
a low order model that is as simple as
possible
but is still able to capture
this kind of response
so now all the plots that you will see
on this last column correspond to
numerical simulations of an ode model
and our starting point is the stuart
landau model which with
correct coefficients sigma and l will
exhibit self-sustained oscillations
at omega 0. if we add a forcing term
we will get a response
at the frequency that we are forcing but
if we
have a harmonic forcing and we want to
get a response at different frequencies
then
we need to add a non-linear term
and these terms that we added here are
modeling
the triadic interactions between the
forcing and the wake modes
finally to generalize or model to
non-harmonic forcing like in our
experiment
we simply replace the harmonic forcing
term with a whole fourier series
so in practice of course you would
truncate this infinite series
and how much will depend on the spectral
decay
of your periodic forcing signal
but typically you can retain only a few
number of terms
with three model parameters that you
need to fit
so let's talk about synchronization what
you see here
are hundreds of fireflies blinking
together on a riverbank in japan
so excited by their neighbors each
individual firefly
slightly adjusts their own blinking rate
until you get what looks like organized
behavior
synchronization theory is a fascinating
field that studies
this kind of behavior for systems such
as chemical reactions
spiking neurons animal locomotion and
many others
and in the last part of our paper we
borrow some of the tools from
synchronization theory
to analyze the dynamics of forced
oscillator
flows as described by our model
so this is our modifieds to our landau
model
and here is where synchronization comes
in because our model is relatively
simple
we can analyze its dynamics using some
classical tools
and i'm going to skip over the details
but you can find all about them in the
method section of the paper
what's important is that we find
analytic expressions for the regions
of synchronization that come in two
flavors what we call
n21 synchronization and n2
synchronization
meaning that n where n is any integer
n cycles of the oscillator flow take
place
for every one or two cycles of the
forcing
and these expressions are parameterized
by the model coefficients
and can be used to delimit what are
known as the arnold tanks of the system
the arnold tongues are the regions in
the space of forcing frequency
and forcing amplitude where the system
synchronizes
to the input so the grade regions
are delimited by our analytic bounds
and the yellow crosses are from our
experimental measurements
and we see remarkable agreement between
approximations made on an ode model
and measurements for from a turbulent
flow field
and as you can see the response of the
wake
in regards to synchronization is quite
different when using symmetric forcing
or anti-symmetric forcing
and i might add that we can also use
these expressions
to enforce known physics on our model
because we have available measurements
of the synchronization bounds
we can use these expressions to solve
for what the model coefficients need to
be
such that by construction our model
respects the synchronization dynamics of
the measured system
and this is a very exciting research
direction that we want to look further
into
in the future
okay so thanks for watching
and again i skipped over a lot of the
details but i invite you to read the
full paper
and you can find a link to it in the
description below thank you